son los primeros nombres del gabinete de
Lula el presidente electo de Brasil
anunció a 16 de sus nuevos ministros que
asumirán junto a él el primero de enero
los ministerios asignados fueron entre
otros Salud Educación ciencia y
tecnología relaciones exteriores defensa
cultura igualdad racial y Derechos
Humanos destacan entre los designados la
asignación del vicepresidente electo
Gerardo alquim en el Ministerio de
industrias y comercio exterior aniel
Franco hermana de la asesinada activista
Mariel y Franco y Silvio Almeida un
activista contra el racismo estarán al
frente de los departamentos de igualdad
racial y Derechos Humanos
respectivamente dos de sus hombres de
confianza figuran en la lista rui Costa
estará al frente del Ministerio de la
presidencia mientras que Fernando jadad
ex alcalde de Sao Paulo estará a cargo
de Hacienda El canciller será Mauro
vieira quien ya realizó estas funciones
bajo las órdenes de Dilma Rousseff Lula
anunció que aumentará 37 los ministerios
el actual gobierno cuenta con 23 no soy
yo quien necesita a los ministros que
anunciamos es el pueblo brasileño quien
los necesita los pobres las mujeres la
población negra nuestro compromiso es
con el pueblo y estoy seguro de que
sabremos cumplirlo aún no se conoce
quién dirigirá el Ministerio de medio
ambiente uno de los nombramientos más
esperados incluso a nivel internacional